Every year has its fair share of highs and
lows at the movies, but some always seem to
stand taller than the others.
With the benefit of 20 years of hindsight,
1999 looks like one of cinema's greatest ever
years and each of these films is well worth
rediscovering as they reach their milestone
anniversaries.
These are some of the best movies turning
20 in 2019.
As the 20th century drew to a close, society
seemed to be spinning headlong into something
of an identity crisis.
It's only fitting, then, that 1999 was also
the year that Fight Club brawled its way into
theaters, and left the world asking: "did
you know the truth about Tyler Durden?"
Unless you were a fan of Chuck Palahniuk's
original book, the answer to that question
was likely no.
Fight Club’s twist is one for the history
books, and has got to be one of the main reasons
why watching David Fincher's film adaptation
unfold was so much fun.
Part scathing indictment of corporate and
consumer culture, part deconstruction of modern
masculine mythos and part exploration of white
male privilege, Fincher's film is a take-no-prisoners
look at a society on the brink of self-destruction
— and in desperate need of a little anarchy.
Fronted by Edward Norton, Brad Pitt and a
marvelously manic Helena Bonham-Carter, anarchy
is just what Fincher and crew deliver with
the brutal and bleak bare-knuckle bout that
is Fight Club — which remains just as potent
and full of surprises 20 years after its release.
Though it takes a radically different approach
to the subject matter, Mike Judge's office
comedy Office Space seems largely cut from
the same thematic cloth as Fight Club.
After all, they're both concerned with the
soul-crushing materialism of society, and
both follow an office drone so drained by
everyday life that they become desperate to
find a way out.
Rather than allow his hypnotist-fractured
psyche to start an underground fight-club-slash-anarchist-revolution,
Judge's protagonist takes a slightly less
violent approach to personal anarchy — he
enlists his buddies in a scheme to shake down
the soulless corporation he works for.
If you've seen Office Space, you’ll know
how hilariously wrong that scheme goes, but
the film isn't really too concerned with the
heist itself.
Instead, Judge uses the setting and plot of
Office Space to spin a not-so-satirical, laugh-out-loud
farce about how effortlessly corporations
and consumerism devour individuality.
And while condemning that culture, Office
Space is also the rare kind of film which
also understands that many people are just
fine toiling away in the corporate digestive
system — so long as they get to keep their
sweet Swingline stapler — and that, if you
aren't one of them...
well, nobody's making you stay.
“Oh, oh, and I almost forgot I’m also
gonna need you to come in on Sunday too, ‘kay?”
Spike Jonze’s wild, frenetic and endlessly
creative film Being John Malkovich may have
netted him an Oscar nomination for Best Director,
but it was hardly his first gig in the director's
chair.
The adventurous filmmaker had spent the bulk
of the '90s honing his skills and developing
his style while directing music videos for
the likes of the Beastie Boys, Weezer, Sonic
Youth, Daft Punk, and Björk.
Where some directors naturally gravitate toward
gritty realism and dense personal drama, Jonze
opts to take those same elements and bolster
them with visually arresting, semi-whimsical
narratives rife with absurdist flights of
fancy and breathtaking stylistic flourishes.
Jonze's style proved more than ideal for Being
John Malkovich, which was scripted by Charlie
Kaufman the poet-laureate of the outlandish
and the eerily eccentric.
Being John Malkovich, which follows the beautifully
bizarre tale of a puppeteer who discovers
a portal into the head of the titular thespian,
is dripping with fantastical flourishes from
both writer and director.
It features show-stopping performances from
John Cusack, Cameron Diaz, Catherine Keener,
and, of course, Malkovich himself.
It also takes more creative and narrative
risks than most films ever dare; making it
not just one of the best films of 1999, but
also one of the all-time greats.
It's almost impossible to imagine now, but
prior to the release of The Matrix almost
nobody knew who the Wachowskis [wuh-CHOW-skees]
were.
After all, they had just two films to their
names, and one of them — the perfectly dreadful
Stallone-and-Banderas-led action flick Assassins
— had only earned them a mere shared screenwriting
credit.
Even their sleek, inventive crime thriller
Bound went all but unnoticed upon release.
Needless to say, expectations were practically
non-existent for the Wachowskis' follow-up,
which was billed as a tech-savvy, effects-driven
action movie featuring Keanu Reeves.
To say the Wachowskis seized the world’s
attention in March of 1999 would be a huge
understatement.
Not only was The Matrix a heady, character-driven
tale of man versus technology run amok, it
was also a groundbreaking visual leap forward
that shaped sci-fi cinema for an entire generation
and became a creative and commercial success
that the Wachowskis could never quite repeat.
They can at least take heart knowing that,
even 20 years after its release, The Matrix
really does feel as fresh and profound as
ever.
“Woah.”
After delivering back-to-back stunners with
his first two films, director Paul Thomas
Anderson had many in the business hailing
him as the next Martin Scorsese.
New Line Cinema stepped up to produce his
third, and he delivered a sprawling, $37 million
art film that followed a dozen or so loosely
connected lives through a single day — and
ever-changing weather patterns — in the
San Fernando Valley.
Clocking in at a whopping three hours and
eight minutes, Magnolia marked Anderson's
most ambitious and personal project to date.
It's a film that seamlessly combined the director's
penchant for high melodrama with his flair
for grandiose set pieces and meticulously
observed, character-driven narratives — all
set against a billboard-sized canvas, and
led by a near-supernatural sense of fate which
is barely even glimpsed in his earlier works.
The result is a colorful mosaic of a movie
that proved to be one of 1999's most challenging
and rewarding releases.
Of all the fantastic movies released in 1999,
few had quite the cultural impact enjoyed
by M. Night Shyamalan's spellbinding supernatural
thriller The Sixth Sense.
Shyamalan's masterpiece arrived in theaters
under a shroud of mystery — but thanks to
a star turn from Bruce Willis, one of the
greatest child performances in history from
Haley Joel Osment and a mind-blowing twist
ending, it became a legitimate cultural phenomenon
almost overnight.
“I see dead people.”
It also cleared well north of half a billion
dollars at the box office, earned six Academy
Award nominations, and made a household name
of the man who wrote and directed it.
Over the years, Hollywood — and Shyamalan
himself — has repeatedly tried and mostly
failed to reproduce the bracing impact of
the film's twisty narrative.
Because Shyamalan's vision is so skillfully
executed and vividly realized, The Sixth Sense
has only grown in esteem as a result, and
the film's hefty emotional impact still hits
home whether you know its secrets or not.
In fact, part of the fun of rewatching The
Sixth Sense is searching for clues that you
missed the first three or four or even five
times through.
But what's often overshadowed by the film's
twist is that, at its core, The Sixth Sense
is also a tenderly observed drama about grief
and loss, fronted by a troubled youth learning
to accept the burdens of a gift he never asked
for.
That Shyamalan fitted such high drama into
a genuinely unsettling ghost story is what
makes The Sixth Sense the stuff of genre legend.
Just a week prior to The Sixth Sense’s arrival
in theaters, another stunning supernatural
confection hit theaters in the form of The
Blair Witch Project.
Conceived and directed by newcomers Daniel
Myrick and Eduardo Sanchez, and starring entirely
unknown actors, the groundbreaking no-budget
feature follows three film students who get
lost in the woods while shooting a documentary
about a small-town urban legend.
As they struggle to find their way back to
society, it becomes clear they're not alone
in the woods, and may be being stalked by
the Blair Witch herself.
While that story would have made an interesting
enough horror film in its own right, it's
how Myrick and Sanchez executed and marketed
their story that really made the The Blair
Witch Project stand apart from pretty much
every found-footage flick made before — or
since.
The directors essentially dropped their actors
off in the woods, orchestrated spooky events
on a daily basis, and had their performers
shoot the action themselves.
The resulting film is gritty and patently
terrifying, and looks and feels just a little
too real for comfort.
The filmmakers even doubled down on that realism
by setting up a genius marketing campaign
that sold the film to audiences as a real-life
documentary.
The stark realism both baffled and enthralled
critics and audiences, which helped make The
Blair Witch Project one of the most profitable
movies ever produced.
Whether you like his movies or not, Stanley
Kubrick is and always will be regarded as
one of the greatest directors that ever lived
if not the greatest.
Whether it was any good or not, his final
film was destined to be one that cinephiles
world would pore over, debate, watch, and
rewatch until the end of time.
To that end, Kubrick, who spent his career
testing the limits of cinema with narratively
challenging and morally ambiguous art films,
continued to push buttons from beyond the
grave with his moody and masterfully-executed
swan song: Eyes Wide Shut.
Based on a 1926 novella entitled Dream Story,
the film follows a man who ends up at this
crazy, kinky house where rich folks wear creepy
masks and do even creepier, kinkier things.
And no, that summation doesn't quite illustrate
the enigmatic power of Kubrick's kinky, semi-surrealist
nightmare.
It doesn't do justice to the complex personal
quandaries explored by the husband and wife
in question, either, and nor does it divulge
the sheer amount of blood, sweat, and tears
put into the film's torturous, two-and-a-half
year production.
While we may never see Kubrick's NC-17 final
cut of Eyes Wide Shut, the version which hit
theaters in 1999 remains a haunting last work
absolutely worth poring over, debating, watching,
and rewatching.
Tim Burton and Johnny Depp may have hit a
bit of a cold streak of late, but there was
once a time when that pairing was one of the
most exciting in Hollywood.
So when they announced they were teaming up
for an adaptation of Washington Irving's short
story The Legend of Sleepy Hollow, there was
more than a little excitement around the project
— mostly because the story jibed so well
with Burton's ability to make the bizarre
and grotesque so endearing and entertaining.
And that's exactly what Burton did with Sleepy
Hollow, which still remains a stunning work
of gothic whimsy.
A crackerjack piece of writing from Seven
scribe Andrew Kevin Walker is largely to thank
— Walker’s script transforms Irving's
brief and brutal Headless Horseman fable into
a complex murder mystery, pitting the skittish
Ichabod Crane as detective on the hunt for
what appears to be a serial killer.
Of course, Crane finds something far more
sinister afoot in the town of Sleepy Hollow,
and a never-better Depp helps draw viewers
further into the eerie unknown with a performance
that teeters between awkward charm, cagey
confidence, and nervy unease.
Thanks to a beautifully bleak visual palette
courtesy of Emmanuel Lubezki, as well as unforgettable
appearances from Christina Ricci and Christopher
Walken, Burton and crew transformed Irving's
classic into a gruesome, gothic fantasia that
stands as the pinnacle of the Burton/Depp
cinematic dynasty.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.